good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
this Tuesday Morning much more needs to
be done warning from the energy
regulator off gem to companies it's
accused of failing vulnerable customers
speaking to the boss of off-gm later
this hour as they tell suppliers to do
better ahead of a difficult winter what
about the football some of you may be
waking up to a sore hedge after Wales
and England were through to the World
Cup campaigns off to a very good start
Gareth Bill's late penalty was enough to
earn Wales A draw against the USA why
while England beat Iran 60 you know all
this dirty but there were no rainbow
armbands and the even more controversy
last night with reports that Welch fans
were stopped from wearing rainbow hats
to the game were live in catch up
Tuesday 22nd of November
named and shaved the energy regulator
off gem hits out its suppliers accusing
them of failing vulnerable customers
ahead of a challenging winter
celebration amid controversy whales draw
their opening World Cup game while
England thrashed Iran in a fixture
marked by protest
our drama are off and on the field there
are reports that some Welsh supporters
had their rainbow colored hats
confiscated before the match
it's a breast controversy here in Doha
after FIFA threats forced Gareth Bale
and Harry Kane to abandon plans to wear
one Lavan band
another blow to the Red Arrows its
commanding officer is removed from post
following allegations of an
inappropriate relationship
hundreds of schools in England lose
their outstanding grade after being
inspected for the first time in years
a race against chime Rescuers search for
survivors amongst the rubble after an
earthquake kills more than 160 people on
Indonesia's main island of java
historic State visit South African
president Sarah ramaphosa will become
the first world leader to be hosted by
the king since his mother's funeral
talk to Ukraine's ambassadors to the UK
after nuclear experts visit the country
and people are warned of winter of
blackouts following Russian attacks on
energy infrastructure
eggsy from the Welsh rap group Goldie
looking chain joins us as they release
an unofficial anthem for all football
morning everyone we'll have the latest
from the World Cup in Kata very shortly
plenty to talk about with our
correspondent there but first the energy
regulator off gem has told 17 suppliers
they must improve their approach to
vulnerable customers as we head into a
very tough winter off gems said failings
included customers missing out on free
gas safety checks vulnerable customers
not being offered the support that they
need and ensuring those on prepayment
meters are identified and supported
although some good practice was
identified all 17 suppliers need to make
further improvements good energy Outfox
so energy true energy and utility would
judge The Worst by offgem
will have more on that with the chief
exec of off Jam in just a few moments
here on the program but first let's tell
you what's happening with the World Cup
and Wales and England have got their
World Cup campaigns off to a good start
Jude Bellingham and the bakario soccer
led the way as England thrashed Iran six
two worlds left it late
um as you know Gareth Bale's 82nd minute
penalty let's get more on this should we
uh Rob is standing by for us hi Rob a
very good morning two years so the team
did well on the pitch lots of
controversy off the pitch
yeah they thought Wales Captain Laura
McAllister had a rainbow bucket hat
confiscated from her you see a lot of
the Wales fans with these bucket hats
it's one of the things they like to
bring to tournaments and yet this is
another sign of the conflict between
FIFA's promise that all fans would be
welcome here and how that message gets
right through to the ground to all the
local security officials and the police
because we've been talking about it
quite a lot this country has those
anti-lgbt laws with same-sex relations
banned and wow FIFA and the Qatari
authorities had insisted rainbow flags
and symbols would be accepted here we've
seen a number of cases where actually
it's led to fans and media even running
into some sort of conflict with those
security we had a journalist an American
journalist who was wearing a rainbow
t-shirt he was detained briefly for
doing so he wasn't allowed into the
stadium and that instant going into the
Wales game last night against the United
States Laura McAllister the former Wales
Captain she said she was told banned
symbol and it was taken offer FIFA
um say they've apologized to her but
what we get to hear is what are they
going to do to ensure actually this does
not happen to other fans at this
tournament yeah and just um I mean this
time yesterday we thought that the uh
home Nations captains were going to be
wearing their one love armbands that
didn't happen suggestions in the papers
here in the UK this morning that the
Qatari government has had something to
do with that what are you hearing
foreign
saying anything about any involvement
from the Qatari government in that
decision we already know that they have
had a big influence on how FIFA are
running this tournament because they had
planned to be selling alcohol outside
stadiums this time last week we heard
the plans despite the fact that alcohol
is not widely available in public spaces
at all it was an exemption was going to
be made for this world cup but on Friday
they suddenly said that actually to
avoid any potential issues around the
game they wouldn't have alcohol there
and that was clearly something that came
right from the top of Qatar because
they're a FIFA sponsor and I did
actually ask the B for president Johnny
Infantino on Saturday that if they can
go back on those assurances how can we
necessarily take their word on other
matters for our more significant matters
particularly about equality and
inclusion so this decision late on by
England Wales to abandon the plans to
wear the one love armbands was something
that can and to some people make FIFA
look like they're suppressing a message
of Tolerance and certainly England and
Wales thought they were being put under
immense pressure that all they wanted to
do was promote equality and yet FIFA
were determining that this was not
something within their allowed permitted
regulations and even some suggestions
that we had thought maybe it would only
be a yellow card for Harry Kane and
Gareth Bale if they wore them that
actually FIFA could have watched
disciplinary proceedings against England
and Wales nose player so maybe they
would have been banned from games and
really seems that FIFA have actually
managed to bring more attention onto
this issue and it goes against their
message of trying to sort of promote
tolerance tolerance and no
discrimination a couple of other quick
points to raise with you a lot of
criticism this morning about David
Beckham in the papers and his support
for the um Qatari government what's the
view there
well obviously here they see him as a
sort of face of the country someone
who's helped me to moat Qatar but I
think they know his silence is causing
issues the fact the only thing we seem
to talk about David Beckham these days
is his
ambassador's deal with Qatar and just
the sort of association with the country
and whether it actually is a deal that
he should have taken particularly when
he's talked up over many years about
LGBT rights and yet of course this as we
say is a country which chess suppresses
LGBT freedoms and the right to have
same-sex relations and we are seeing
them at games we're seeing him
celebrating for instance at the England
game and uh yeah we're still waiting to
actually hear from him just to talk
about even his association with it with
Qatar but we see many groups obviously
questioning why he took the deal indeed
um but let's finish on the football
should we um who did England and Wales
play next
well for England next it is the United
States they also played them at the 2010
World Cup when they drew their World Cup
opener there and for Wales it's Iran and
you know they'll be hoping particularly
having seen the uh performance by
England against Iran that may be there's
some hope for them to get uh their win
at this world cup which could help them
in terms of progressing then of course
it all builds up to the big finale in
group b when we get England against
Wales will something still be at stake
in that match for both teams will they
have secured their passage already and
today is a day actually with Argentina
in action when we hope to see Lionel
Messi when he finally win uh a World Cup
as one of the world's best players
that's the big trophy missing from his
cabinet yeah I think I read this morning
Lionel Messi and his debut for Argentina
was sent off after 45 seconds let's see
what happens today thanks so much indeed
for now Rob uh thank you and lots of
excitement of course yesterday six goals
for England
um one of the last ones I'll scored I
should say by the midfielder Jack
greylish and he still managed to keep
his promise to an 11 year old boy called
Finley who met earlier this year have a
quick look
at this
you want to do this yeah all right I'll
do that for you all right I promise but
remember I've got a score though next
time next time of school yeah all right
then I'll do that for you so what is it
just like this yeah yeah all right deal
come here
uh uh greatly celebrating his girl with
the dance that he planned with Finley
Finley who has cerebral palsy met the
England player after writing to him to
say he was inspired by greylish speaking
about his younger sister Holly who also
has cerebral palsy had actually asked
him whether he would do the worm and he
said no I won't but I'll do this and
indeed he did which was fantastic and he
scored a girl and if you can scan your
QR code on the screen here it comes uh
there it is you can listen to the latest
edition of The Sky News Daily podcast
looking into the World Cup armbands
around and speaking to LGBT plus
football fans about why they believe the
sport has scored an own goal
yeah
also still to come on the program before
you joined by the former International
Trade secretary and Tori MP Liam Fox the
odg regulator has accused suppliers of
failure across the board speaking to off
gems director of retail Neil Lawrence
later this hour
Labor's Shadow business secretary
Jonathan Reynolds will be joining us
shortly after eight o'clock
before all of that though let me tell
you what's happening in Indonesia a
story that was breaking as we were going
off there yesterday morning rescue
efforts underway for survivors of the
earthquake there which has killed at
least 162 people the governor of West
Java said many of the Dead were children
killed while taking extra lessons after
the end of their school day
the main area affected is the Shinju
region in the west of java Nicole
hasmore
flattened buildings and mountains of
concrete the aftermath of a 5.6
magnitude earthquake that struck the
island of java
dozens of people have been killed and
hundreds injured as Rescuers search for
survivors
homes were not built to withstand the
force of a quake like this
I was crying and immediately grabbed my
husband and children if I didn't pull
them out we might have become victims
the house was shaking as if it was
dancing
it struck near the town of chenjur in
the middle of the day the local Governor
says schools were hit hard and most of
those killed were children
field hospitals have been set up in the
streets everywhere survivors in the
middle of this chaotic crowded Community
most suffered a broken bone or were
injured because of falling objects and
incision wounds and there were also
around 13
784 evacuees
Crews worked through the night to save
lives there's been dozens of aftershocks
and access is difficult in remote areas
with roads blocked by landslides people
embracing themselves for a large number
of dead foreign
this country is no stranger to
earthquakes it's in an area known as the
Pacific Ring of Fire one of the most
active regions in the world for volcanic
eruptions and tremors
the trauma of this one will linger as
the enormity of This Disaster sinks in
Nicole Johnston Sky News
well joining us now is Dr Liam Fox
previously a member of the government
conservative MP for North Somerset so
much to talk to you about I wonder if I
might be able to ask you about energy
bills if that's okay
um we're just hearing from off gem that
vulnerable customers are being ripped
off by big energy companies in all sorts
of ways I'm sure that some of your
constituents are going to be affected by
that not least those that are on
prepayment meters
um is there anything you can do about it
I think it's something that the big
energy companies need to look at the
government the taxpayers you and I are
putting in a lot of money to help
especially those on Lower incomes and I
think the energy companies need to be
doing the same to make sure that tariffs
and charges are as Fair as possible and
that the money that taxpayers putting in
will therefore go as far as possible
yeah um do you think the government is
doing enough I mean there were some
suggestions that the government
shouldn't get involved in in I mean
obviously the coming up with a lot of
money but they shouldn't get involved in
support schemes to help customers
because that was too much of a nanny
State given that we're hearing from
off-gen that people for example people
on on prepayment meters are just
suffering at the hands of several of
these energy companies is it an area
where the government should perhaps look
at it that again I think it's something
that Parliament will want to look at I'm
sure that select committees will want to
look at whether the public money that's
being put in an extra 26 billion that
the government announced last week which
is more than half of our defense budget
to put that in perspective that needs to
be used properly so I think that the
parliament all MPS will want to ensure
that that money is being used in an
effective way to help those especially
at lowest a low income levels you know
previous prime minister said that we
would be helping people with Energy caps
for two years the new chancellor has
said we'll look at it again in April is
that right well it depends on what of
course is happening to Energy prices the
reason that we're having this high level
of support is because of the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and how stop oil and
gas prices around the world if those
prices start to fall again clearly we
don't want to be having taxpayer subsidy
where we don't really need to have that
because we've got lots of other
priorities where we could be spending
that money so it's always a balance
about where the government uses
taxpayers money uh you don't want to be
putting subsidies in unnecessarily but
the government will look at it and see
where we need to Target that support
we've seen some evidence of those global
prices in oil and gas beginning to fall
again
but it's anyone's guess over the winter
and what will happen we don't know how
severe the winter in Europe will be what
demand will be and what that will do for
prices none of us can predict that
something that is an area of expertise
here of course is brexit we're hearing
from senior European figures say it's
wishful thinking that we could get
closer to the EU when it comes to trade
deals without
um with a special deal without agreeing
to free movement of people yeah I'm sure
they're right and I think this idea of
first of all I think politically
reopening the debate on brexit is the
very last thing that we need at the
present time and this talk about a Swiss
relationship you know for the Swiss they
have to pay into the European budget
they have to accept free movement of
people and they have to accept European
laws over which they've got no control I
don't see that as being in line any in
any way shape or form
um with the spirit of our referendum or
our exit from the European Union I think
it's a political non-starter it's a
waste of everybody's energy and we
should just get on with the job in hand
you say get on with the job in hand but
we don't enough have enough people to
get on with the job in hand there are
hundreds of millions of job vacancies
and I think one and a half million job
vacancies at the moment yes but and we
also have a very large number of people
who are out of work or an even bigger
number of people who are not
economically active so what we're going
to do with it so well so one of the
interesting things about the budget and
something that a lot of us have been
talking about is is why so many people
have chosen not to work as we know a lot
of people from the age 55 bracket uh
onwards and have chosen not to work
since the pandemic I think we need to
try to understand why that is and try to
find if we can find attractive ways to
bring these people back into the economy
whether that's part-time or otherwise
then I think the other thing to remember
about brexit
and immigration is this that we are
needing to deal with illegal immigration
but the point of brexit wasn't to stop
immigration it was to give us control of
immigration and I think that we're there
are areas of the economy where we need
more skilled people more quickly than I
think that we should use those freedoms
of brexit to try to achieve that the
whole point of brexit was to give us
back control it wasn't to have any one
policy imposed upon us two questions as
a result of what you said there um if we
try to make if the government tries to
make uh coming back to work for the over
55 is more attractive and that doesn't
work do you do you go for less
attractive ways to get them to come back
to work now I know you're trying to
encourage people back into the world you
can't force people into the workforce
this is a free country that people
choose not to work and they've got the
savings for example they can look at
their at their benefits can't you well
if people are have savings and they're
not on benefits for example they're
they're entitled not to work if they can
afford to do so people who put money
aside I think we try to want to try to
encourage more people back into that
Workforce because
um if we don't have the domestic
Workforce you've got two choices the
jobs don't get done or you have to bring
them in from elsewhere and people need
to have to I think as a national uh
conversation we need to decide you know
which of these options is most
attractive to us we we do need to have a
growing economy and that means a
Workforce is becoming either bigger or
more productive or both
um but if we can't do that domestically
uh we can't just leave the jobs unfilled
no but we need a more skilled work for
so she was saying now that takes time
there are skilled workers in Europe who
could come and fill those jobs for now
yes and if you know as I said as I said
the point of brexit was to give us
control over migration and if we need so
you're not rejecting that idea to bring
skilled workers more skilled workers no
no I'm absolutely not and I think that
we need to use our freedoms to be able
to use
um those those uh those powers to be
able to match the requirements of our
economy with those skills that may Exist
Elsewhere what we can't have is free
movement with people where people are
coming to the UK who may not have the
skills that we want but ultimately
become able to use our public services
or our benefits
um the PM also said we're in control of
our borders now because we are no longer
attached to the EU but we still have to
deal with countries like France don't we
on a daily basis so we're just picking
and choosing well I think on the
question of migration I think we have to
have a wider view frankly of what the
problem is and I would say you can break
it into three parts you've got those who
are crossing from France into the UK at
the present time France has its own
problems because of the Schengen
agreement the free movement of people in
Europe effectively if you can get into
the southern border of Greece you can
get to Calais because there are no
restrictions across European borders and
then we've got a very big Global problem
largely I think because of the pandemic
where you've had a lot of dis of people
who have been uh displaced economically
by the pandemic looking for a better
life and of course we live in a world
now where if you're a young African with
a mobile phone you can see what
Prosperity looks like and if that's
being denied to you you will try to get
something better for yourself I think
that's a normal human reaction I think
therefore we have to think of the
Upstream if you like elements of that
migration problem including how do we
ensure that developing countries get
their fair share of prosperity and the
post-pandemic we're not putting them at
an economic disadvantage because of of
elements in the global trading system
it's it's a it's a it's a problem with a
lot of different layers and I think a
lot of the political debate is too
simplistic complex problems as I would
say as a doctor seldom have a simple
solution to them glad you brought up the
fact that you're a doctor I'm reading in
the paper today that um Rishi sunac
um says that the NHS is in his blood but
he pays 250 pounds to see a doctor as
soon as possible he enrolls in an agency
that will do that for him how does he
square that Circle to say that you know
he's in his blood and the NHS is his
number one priority but if he's got an
ache or a pain he can just jump the
queue well he's judged by what he does
in terms of public policy I think that
the government is judged by what it does
for the NHS and how much money do what I
say not as I do no the government is
judged the politicians are judged by the
public policy and what they do for the
NHS we've seen record sums going into
the NHS the NHS has two particular
problems at the present time number one
is inflation so even with a big increase
being put in that that will eat that up
and the second is we've got a chronic
problem in the NHS with people being
unable to be discharged from our
hospitals yeah because they're problems
with social care well it's partly that
it's partly I would also argue a lack of
uh capacity inside the NHS now it's a
long time since I worked in a hospital
but even then we had a problem with the
inability to discharge patients who were
perfectly ready to go for making
hospital my point my point is should
somebody who says that the NHS is in his
blood and he's responsible for where the
money goes be jumping the queue by
paying 250 quid to see a private doctor
rather than where she seen a fortnight
like the rest of us well it's the Prime
Minister and the government are judged
by what they do for the NHS what they do
which private money is up to them but I
don't have private insurance but I don't
in any way think that people should not
do that if that's what they choose to do
and remember everybody does that even if
they're the Prime Minister well and what
does that say about the Optics well it
anyone is entitled to do that this is a
free country and and it cannot be that
we tell some people that they cannot do
that the government is judged by what
it's doing for the NHS and the NHS is
getting a lot of extra money we're
trying to deal with those problems of
capacity in the NHS and the fact that
the NHS is suffering from a huge number
of job vacancies at the present time but
people are not going into so that's not
going to be helps nor does the debate
get out it's some rich bloke who is
telling us how to live our lives and yet
and taxing us more and yet he can jump
the queue when it suits him well the
prime minister's job is to make sure
that the public provision of Health in
this country is as good as it can be
both his time as a Chancellor now as
prime minister we're seeing record sums
going into the NHS that's the job of
politicians appreciate how that might
not sit well with my viewers this
morning well lots of people in this
country will choose to use either the
savings or private uh Health policies to
be able to get Private health care every
time someone does that it's less strain
on the NHS I mean if you want to get rid
of Private health care you'll get an
even bigger stream on the NHS the
government's job is to make sure the NHS
is well run and is well funded and under
Rishi sunach and this government I'm
confident it will be so you don't think
for one second that people will find it
um they'll have to hold their nose when
they read about this story well people
will get Private health care through
their companies to the trade unions and
through the trade unions in some cases
so I don't see why that's uh any
different as I said the job of the
government to make sure the NHS is well
run and it's well funded and that's
what's happening at my presence okay now
I know Scotland are not in the World Cup
I'm sorry to rub that in but how did you
find the games yesterday
well I'm a little worried that um Iran
could get two goals against England
and um I'm a bit I think they've got one
girl against Scotland though didn't they
last time you played them that's and it
was a draw that is not a bar that I
would necessarily apply okay
um and I think that the world should be
disappointed
um with the draw so it's uh it's going
to be an interesting tournament there's
uh there's a lot to fight for still and
who's gonna win
I have no idea uh Tina
um I haven't really have no idea as long
as it's not Argentina frankly
I don't really have any countries that I
don't want to win and you know
something that a lot of people have been
saying is um can we just talk about the
football and not try to politicize what
I was trying to do every single bit
um of it and if we can get back to sport
a sport yeah so much more helpful and
you know if we have fewer TV um
commentators lecturing us about uh
climate change and immigration and other
issues and actually still talk to us
about football I think a lot of viewers
will be a lot happier okay it's good to
talk to you Doctor as always thanks very
much indeed for joining us thank you a
quick look at the papers for you this
morning in the football featuring on the
front of many of them the Metro reports
on England's World Cup win and Praises
Iran's players for their protests over
the Crackdown on anti-government
demonstrations at home
some has a picture of the opening go
Jude Bellingham
yeah go on boy and the mirror also
covers England's win and the highlights
FIFA's ban on one of armbands which a
number of captains wanted to wear but
decided not to
current commanding officer of the Red
Arrows let's talk about him he's been
removed from his post following
allegations of a relationship with a
junior colleague in 2017. when Commander
David Montenegro will now be the subject
of an RAF investigation though there is
no suggestion of sexual abuse or
harassment Emma standing by for is at
the mod this morning hi Emma what more
can you tell us about this story good
morning
hello okay yes more bad news for the Red
Arrows following news that there'd been
an investigation
um following a reports of unacceptable
Behavior within the world-renowned
aerobatics team and that resulted in
various disciplinary action including
um some dismissals and now we hear that
the administrative head of the Red
Arrows Wing Commander David Montenegro
himself removed from his post following
these allegations that he had been
involved in an inappropriate
relationship with a junior colleague as
reported in the Daily Mail apparently
flown back from a high-profile tour of
the Gulf States and this relates to the
time when he was read one which is the
most senior pilot within the Red Arrows
now there has been a statement from the
RAF and have said all RAF Personnel are
expected to maintain the highest
standards of behavior the RAF is aware
of historic allegations from 2017 that
have been made against the current
officer command in the r aerobatic team
the Red Arrows which will be thoroughly
investigated pending that investigation
and without prejudice the individual has
been removed from post we will not be
commenting further while the
investigation is ongoing but the RAF
have made it clear that there are there
is a clear code of conduct a document
and that the cohesion of the unit relies
on Mutual trust and respect extensive
training is underway within the unit to
try and improve the culture there but as
it stands at the moment the head of the
Red Arrows has been suspended from his
role while an investigation into his own
behavior is carried out okay Emma thank
you
also making news for you today hundreds
of schools in England which had been
rated outstanding have been downgraded
after many were inspected for the first
time in more than a decade Watchdog
ofsted says only 17 of those checked
remained in the top tier
scientists believe they could double the
survival of people with Advanced cancer
within a decade experts from The
Institute of cancer research and the
Royal Marsden NHS Foundation trust said
Cutting Edge research on what they
describe as the cancer ecosystem will
mean more people will be cured While
others will live far longer
supermarkets are taking advantage of
customers by charging far higher fuel
prices than they should be the motoring
Services Company the RAC says that
wholesale costs of fuel have dropped but
prices to customers have not they want
an immediate cut of five pence per liter
boss of Virgin Atlantic has warned that
the Heathrow expansion will be difficult
to support unless there's an overhaul of
Regulation at the airport Heathrow is
continuing to develop its plan to build
a third Runway after legal challenges
and covert delays Shave Ice has
criticized the airport's attempt to
raise charges and its decision to limit
capacity
her studies revealed that just one in
seven Black Friday deals offer a genuine
discount who knew and the vast majority
of items on sale are cheaper all the
same price in the six months before
after analyzing several major online and
High Street retailers the Watchdog which
found that not a single item on sale was
at its cheapest on Black Friday
who would ever have guessed that now our
twins born from embryos Frozen more than
30 years ago are believed to have set a
new record Lydia and Timothy Ridgeway
were born at the end of last month after
what their parents described as a
mind-boggling experience their father
was just five years old when the embryos
were created in 1992.
that's amazing isn't it fantastic uh
King Charles is set to host the first
state visit of Israel when he welcomes
South Africa's president Sarah ramaphosa
to the UK joined now by the former UK
High Commissioner to South Africa Lord
boating hello to you my Lord thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning talk to us about your hopes and
expect it could hello uh talk to me
about your hopes and expectations for
this visit
this is an important visit uh for
Britton South Africa is our major
strategic partner on the continent our
biggest trade partner Britain 2 is a
major investor in South Africa and the
bonds are are strong but there are a
number of key issues climate change the
foremost amongst them South Africa is
very heavily Reliant uh on coal it needs
at the same time to see jobs created so
delivering on the uh outcome of the
Egyptian uh cop will be hugely important
both for South Africa and of course uh
for for Britain and it's the first in
King Charles's Reign and that too is
significant because King Charles has a
long-standing relationship uh with uh
Africa built up over many years with him
making a significant contribution of
course to the preservation of Africa's
environment and Wildlife yeah and of
course his boy is very much involved in
Africa as well as was his uh former wife
um there are challenges though aren't
there I mean South Africa is and I've
been there very recently there have um
significant uh problems when it comes
um to energy
um economic stagnation as well and and
the president himself is not without
controversy
I was present yesterday at South Africa
house and I think the theme for
president ramaphosa's visit will be no
one left behind uh that uh no uh one in
South Africa should not benefit uh from
uh development that the real challenge
is they face should be addressed and
they see trade and investment as a very
important part in that but South Africa
also demands and rightly uh respect it
won't be lectured about its spells its
neutral stance uh in international
Affairs and it looks uh to Britain and
the Commonwealth as equal and respectful
partners and the Commonwealth indeed
provides a good context for that sense
of mutual friendship responsibility but
but founded on a relationship respect
for individual sovereignty
we very much remember Nelson Mandela
coming along to have a state visit I
think back in 1996 now I remember him
addressing uh both the houses of
Parliament at the time that visit went
down very well
um indeed can Cyril ramaphosa expect
anything along the same lines
there was something of course very
special about Nelson Mandela that no one
can hope to emulate uh but Cyril
ramaphosa is someone who's made a real
contribution on the world stage and
indeed to peace in Northern Ireland he
was a major interlocutor during that
very difficult time in helping negotiate
the peace Accord with Shinn Fein he's
someone who is rightly respected and
someone who understands the needs of a
business who understands the importance
of building a dynamic economy so I've
got no doubt that this will be a
successful visit but it needs to be a
visit that is rooted in neutral respect
and understanding of the challenges that
the whole world faces around climate
change and the UK has an opportunity to
become for South Africa a major
strategic partner in addressing the
issue issue of climate change and I
think it will do that I wonder my Lord
if you could um talk to our viewers this
morning about some of the controversy
surrounding the Cullen and diamonds
suggestions that our Queen should should
not wear that today that it would cause
offense to our South African friends and
neighbors uh what what is the
controversy surrounding it
I think there just needs to be an
understanding on all sides that history
is a complex matter we need in the UK as
a country to face up uh to the reality
of our Imperial past we need also to
recognize that there is the eight case
for the return of many of the artifacts
held in our museums uh I don't think the
issue of a diamond in a crown is going
to Mar the relationship between the UK
and South Africa but I do feel that it's
very important that we understand the
complexities of history that we face up
to our responsibilities and things were
some things that were wrong and that
where we can we make adequate and proper
reparation but the key you know and this
is what I've found both are as a high
commission and indeed as a cabinet
minister with responsibility for the
Africa commission the key to good
relationships going forward is respect
for the past of course and its
complexity but above all respect now in
terms of a relationship of equals and I
think South Africa and Britain can do
that South Africa is a great country
it's been through many trials and
tribulations Britain has played its part
in that but let's not forget either that
whatever British governments in the past
have done the relationship between
British people and South African people
has always been one that has been based
on that respect we saw that in the
anti-apartheid movement when Britain and
British people whatever the government's
position when British people were the
Forefront of the struggle for freedom in
South Africa and we need to build on
that relationship uh between peoples I
remember when I I was like commissioner
rugby broke people together uh sport can
bring people together and One Believes
and hopes that South Africa and Britain
have a great future together but one
based on respect for each other's
sovereignty and building okay uh future
together yeah who are you supporting in
the world cup to that end
uh I want a Ghana and England to be in
the finals and if we achieve that that
would be a great thing for both England
and Ghana after that well it's in the
hands of the Gods ah good answer it's
good to talk to you my Lord thank you
good seeing you as ever okay bye thank
you bye-bye the energy regulator of gem
has told 17 suppliers they must improve
their approach to vulnerable customers
as we head into a tough winter join my
body director of retail at offgen that's
Neil Lawrence hello to Mr Lawrence
thanks for joining us on the program
um this morning
um so tell me more about these companies
what are they up to
so we know right now that customers are
struggling energy is an essential
service and all customers especially
those most vulnerable need to have
confidence that they will be treated
appropriately when they contact their
energy supplier so to drive standards up
across the industry often is undertaken
its latest Deep dive into vulnerable
customers to assess how they're served
and today we publish those results
the severe weaknesses across five
supplies moderate weaknesses and another
five and seven have minor weaknesses
and undertaking that review
um we we've agreed action plans with all
those suppliers and they're going to
deliver those action plans now and we
want them to demonstrate they've taken
this seriously and so those vulnerable
customers when they contact Energy
supplier know that they get all the
support that they deserve yeah how are
you going to hold these companies to
account I mean taking advantage of
vulnerable customers with a Long Winter
ahead is just not acceptable
yeah absolutely so our expectations are
really clear the suppliers should be
practically checking and recording where
a customer is in a vulnerable situation
and if customers don't volunteer that
information supplies agents should be
trained to spot the signs of
vulnerability and then they can provide
them with access to all the support that
is available that might include put them
on the priority service register
checking they've got access to all that
government support that we really
welcome now ultimately if they if
suppliers fail to take the steps that we
have agreed in those action plans we've
got further sanctions including fines
further enforcement action and
ultimately we can take licenses away if
suppliers don't comply with our rules
and that's what we're going to do
so just talk me through that in more
detail
so in terms of our next steps every
supplier has an action plan that has
details of what they need to do to
improve the support for vulnerable
customers and we will um we will review
their action plans with the suppliers
and where they fail to take the
appropriate steps to make sure that
fundable customers are supported we will
go through further sanctions including
fines further enforcement action and
ultimately if necessary we can take not
licenses away all of this is possible
why the package a practice deep Dives
Angel Drive standards up in the industry
energy is an essential service and when
customers call they deserve that service
to be given to them we've already looked
at direct debits customers in payable
difficulty and we'll report also on
customer services later this year
and we also wrote to suppliers earlier
this year on the PPM switching issue
yeah but just
about how many of these that have been
highlighted so far these seven
um businesses I think it's seven I'm
just gonna um list them as we're talking
to you good energy out Fox so energy or
so energy true energy utility five how
many of those if they don't pull their
socks up might lose their licenses
but we treat all suppliers the same we
go through a robust process so every
book we're looking at all suppliers
across the market yeah but you've
Illustrated that these are not up to
scratch so how many of these are in risk
of losing their license if they don't
sort themselves out well we've agreed
action plans with everybody in the
industry over this issue whilst we want
to realize is that nobody achieved the
green standard that we'd accept expect
and that's very important at this stage
vulnerable customers deserve to be
treated properly now we are seeing that
this process is working so we are seeing
suppliers take proactive action now off
the back of our market-wide compliance
review or deep dive approach and we're
seeing them take undertake action
themselves proactively such as
independent audits into direct debits
and taking an approach to proactively
make sure the process they have in place
will support customers that's what we
want to see that proactive engagement to
up the standards within the industry
that's the conversation that we want to
drive as I said ultimately if suppliers
don't do that we do have sanctions
available to us
why did you not do this before
we changed our approach earlier this
year as I said to undertake that
proactive assessment in a range of areas
um that's been um a changing approach
it's a welcome approach it's aimed at
driving standards up across the industry
we're looking to make sure that when
customers call contact their energy
Supply they will get the service that
they deserve it's really important at
the backdrop of the current cost of
living crisis that when all customers
contact their energy Supply especially
those that are in vulnerable situations
they get the service that they deserve
and they get access to all the help that
is available
okay thank you
thanks so much
tomorrow is here um this morning lots
for the government to face up to uh
today not least the fact that kistama is
speaking to the CBI today brexit still
very much on the agenda as is what's
happening with off Gem and companies
that are not supporting people well
enough and what's the story about the
Prime Minister paying for private
appointments for a GP when other people
are waiting a fortnight that's right
story in the guardian today saying that
uh Rishi sinak who of course has talked
a lot about the NHS about how his
parents were a GP and a pharmacist said
the NHS is in my blood and a speech to
the CBI Only Yesterday the Guardians say
that he uses a private GP surgery which
charges 250 pounds for an appointment on
the day so the suggestion they're making
is that while lots of people have to
wait two weeks for an appointment if not
longer the Prime Minister may not
understand their concerns if he's able
to get one straight away now some Tory
MPS think this story is a bit unfair and
in fact number 10 have not denied it
they're not commenting on it at all in
fact and a sourcing government said to
me that you know Richard Cena should be
judged on what he's doing for the NHS
and he saw him put in 6.6 billion pounds
in the Autumn statement only last week
so they're very much hitting back the
idea that you should judge people on
their own personal medical choices and
they won't be commenting on his but
certainly um as the NHS is and it's and
how overstretched it is is people's top
concern you can see why this story has
appeared labor also not commenting on
that story Labor's big intervention
today is actually on migration and it's
um really interesting one actually
because kirst armor who of course for
many people was associated with wanting
to stay in the EU with having a second
referendum is actually addressing the
CBI today and he's saying the era of
cheap labor is over and companies need
to upskill British workers and he says
if he was prime minister he wouldn't try
and stop people coming to this country
if they were needed but he's saying if
businesses want more visas then they
also have to show what they're doing on
skills so it's a big move for labor I
think and saying that they support the
current migration Arrangements but just
want to make them work more effectively
and as far as this off-gem reports is
concerned some suggestions that the
government should be more involved
whereas the government is saying we
don't want to be a nanny State that's
right so off gem found 17 companies had
let down the most vulnerable customers
basically not fulfilled their
responsibilities in terms of setting
their debt repayments too high not doing
some of the things they're supposed to
do for free like gas checks or reading
meters for people who can't do it
themselves so they have failed in their
legal responsibilities and you heard Lee
and fox there saying you know Parliament
will want to look at at this issue yes
it comes in a context of the government
being criticized for not wanting to tell
people the measures that they can take
around the home to save energy because
they were afraid of you know looking uh
you know it backfiring on them
essentially but I'm sure MPS will want
to draw a line between these companies
legal responsibilities and just helping
people to save energy but um certainly
the idea that at the moment when people
are facing bills of thousands of pounds
that these companies aren't doing the
bare minimum to help the most vulnerable
customers is something that I think we
can expect MPS to get quite angry about
Yeah tomorrow's take at nine o'clock
looking forward to it thanks very much
indeed tomorrow thank you back to the
World Cup now in England have got their
campaign off to a storming start
apparently they won six two I've not
mentioned it this morning how about do I
know by England's Super Fan and host of
the this dotted football podcast that's
Billy Grant hi Billy
hi Kay how you doing I am great tell me
about the match yesterday
match yesterday was brilliant I mean I
was lucky to get there actually because
I did a bit of a roundabout route as you
do I went to the Tel Aviv and then flew
in by Jordan and then into the game and
all my flights were delayed Roy
Jordanian were a complete nightmare but
anyway and uh I've got him back
two hours
before the old kickoff and I got to
accommodate about a million miles queue
so I had to dump my bags to change
myself in a in a store room and we got
to the game five minutes before kickoff
so I was a little bit nervous at the
time I thought oh my God we're gonna
make kickoff but we got there and to be
honest with you the team did us proud
because they started off on the front
foot scored some great goals played some
really great football the fans were
oh we are um we've got good shakes like
you know even the Iranian fans they're
really good really good
um tell me what the energy was like in
the stadium Billy
oh I think we've lost Billy just um for
now but let's bring in um John Rutledge
why we saw that I AKA eggsy of course
member of Goldie looking chain uh hiya
morning how are you good morning I am
very well tell me about the game last
night
powerful game uh what's firstly I'd like
to point out that you're speaking to the
least knowledgeable football fan of the
GLC but I can't say it was incredibly
powerful game super slow first off we
all know that I'll be told to say this
but apparently that penalty wow
fantastic they only came up with the
goods one one all right could have been
two one could have been three one could
have been four one five one six one but
it was one one hopefully there'll be
some more gold score further down the
line so brilliant absolutely brilliant a
game with two cars and they were some
great cards
talk to me about the song
well of course as you know uh golly
looking chain one of Britain's favorite
uh moderately successful pop groups have
just released our great YouTube football
football very easy to learn very catchy
um it's simply well simply goes football
football football football football
football football
goals it's a song for anyone you could
be a Wales fan you could be an England
fan you could follow Uruguay any team
that like this song is for you it's the
unofficial World Cup anthem for anyone
and I tell you what it's kicking right
off at the moment
let's have a quick listen to the video
should we go on okay
got it
um hugely important time for Wells and I
think at first time for more than 60
years that the team has got to
um a World Cup final
um tell me is it was it that that made
you think you know what I need to make a
video or or do you always make one
well I think you know we've done a few
in the past and and at the moment that
everybody's doing it these days and we
were like should we do one and then
Reese will put the tune together and
start humming that and Adam was in the
back absolutely hated it and he said
he's giving me another beat let's record
it and we are done and it's out there
and it's going down well people seem to
be enjoying it so that's that's great
you know
um yeah it's just it's just a lot of fun
and it's a good way of celebrating the
fact that whales are doing so well as
you know Wales is the greatest country
in the world so this is it this is a
great time for people to see the full
power of Wales yeah that's absolutely
what Welsh people say
um what do you make about Gareth Bale
not wearing his one love armband
uh well you know it's it's up to him
what decision he makes you know if he
wants to do that that's fine I'm not
going to slag him off you know every
man's a free Manner and he can do what
he wants just remember it's nice to be
important it's more important to be nice
guys uh that's uh very true
um what about the Welch fans having
their their hats taken away from them I
mean is catter the right place I mean
we're getting slightly political just
for a minute but it's kind of the right
place for a World Cup for the first time
Wales playing in 60 years are you glad
that it's in Qatar very interesting
question I think it's a question on
everybody's lips at the moment you know
if I was putting it on I would have done
it in you bought in the county ground we
were like the old thing going on there
everybody would have been happy but I
think
these FIFA Lads have got their own
decisions and obviously somebody thought
would be a good idea to do it there up
to you mate I haven't got any power up
for this but like I said the next World
Cup I am happy to get it organized and
put it on a new book just give me a call
if you work for the fa I can sort that
fantastic
um how do you think Wales are going to
get on against Iran that's the next game
I think uh 15 nil
um bale of score them all and
um with that performance I think they'll
just give us the World Cup anyway I
think that's just the nature
uh it's great to talk to you thanks so
much indeed for sharing that video with
us really appreciate it thanks a lot I
think Billy take care I think Billy's
back with us hi Billy we lost you there
I was asking you about the mood in the
stadium yesterday
mood is great mood was great the
atmosphere is fantastic the locals are
great the Iranians were great the
English fans were great we just really
enjoyed it I'll tell you something you
know and that's to say you start off on
the right foot you have a result like
that and it just makes everyone relax
and that's what everyone did and had a
really good time and had a really good
night
it looked as though it was a carnival
atmosphere players relaxing they had
their sliders on they were hugging their
babies their wives and girlfriends were
with them as well do you think
um actually they're in Qatar there is
any feeling that it's the wrong place to
be for this World Cup final as the
papers are suggesting here in the UK
I mean listen this will you know we can
have this conversation forever I mean
for me I was gutted when Qatar got the
World Cup because for me I would have I
would have preferred to have gone to
another places to go and watch the
football I'm also a little bit gutted
that a lot of my friends wouldn't come
out here for various reasons either
whether or not it's too expensive they
thought it was going to be or because of
various reasons because they were you
know a little bit scared coming over
LGBT fans I know were scared to come
over for so for those reasons I don't
know that they they relayed I I laid
enough fears they didn't turn around the
people and actually make them feel
um comfortable enough to come which I
think is a real shame if you come out
here you know there are fans out here
but there aren't the the droves of fans
that you thought they're going to be I
think the numbers have been slightly
slightly massaged I think you know I'm
saying England fans I don't know maybe
2000 fans out here you know and and
there should be a lot more but also the
other thing is that's really riled me is
I'm staying in a shipping container
right and literally it is a shipping
container somebody's come in he's
drilled holes in the windows putting
windows inside there put in the bathroom
you know and and you walked in and you
think okay fair enough I'm a football
fan you know if I've got certain budget
they'll come stay in here but this
shipping container which is really badly
made and there's about you know
thousands of them all in the same area
like you know with loads of football
bands in there it's costing like 180
pounds a night now if the World Cup
really wanted to attract bands because
it's all about getting the right budget
they would have made that like 30 pound
a night and then it would have attracted
more people over to have a really good
time so that's one of the things that's
actually earned me a little bit to say
actually have you really thought about
the fans over here but other than that
listen they've been very friendly the
locals have been brilliant um but the
organization is a little bit squiffy
okay uh Billy we are out of time but
it's great to talk to you hopefully
you'll stay in touch and we can talk to
you again after the game against the US
so now thanks so much indeed thanks a
lot okay thank you